another musician making headlines today
Britney Spears who has triggered fresh
concern from fans after posting this
bizarre Instagram video Let's Go
so guys
I just want you to know if I shut down
my Instagram do not call the cops I
don't ever be a roller coaster
appears to be a British accent the 41
year old shows off various dresses
before running off screen once again I
got this dress as well never bear
what I'm seeing you know just again from
the outside that her mind is delusional
right now up down up down up down the
manic stages last month officers did
visit Brittany's home after fans
requested a wellness check when she
deleted her Instagram thank you company
pushing you needed stress a few hours
after this post has been Sam askgari
shared a video where you can hear
Britney's typical accent while giving
him a facial this is 200 extra kisses no
thank you I want money as for what's
going on with Brittany behind the scenes
we're told two weeks ago friends and
family plan to Stage an intervention
which did not occur our source says
Brittany has quote struggled with drugs
over the years Ken Seeley who helped
guide many families in crisis on the a e
reality series intervention explains the
best way to support an individual who
doesn't want help I never worked with
Brittany but I know mental illness what
it's going to take to get her back on
track is that intervention they were
trying to do that's the only thing
that's really going to help save her
life I didn't die I'm here I'm alive I'm
well and uh that's it that's it skip
skip skip skip
[Music]